after World War II the global Community
for the most part came to the conclusion
that invading your neighbors to take
land wasn't okay anymore yet in 1961
India invaded the Portuguese overseas
territory of Goa to incorporated into
the country and write what the Indian
government saw as a historic wrong but
given that India simply marched its Army
into the territory of a Western European
nation this raises a question how did
the world react to this and why didn't
anybody try to stop India so as you'll
know India gained its independence from
Britain in 1947 alongside Pakistan and
despite Britain being gone there were
other European countries which still
held territory in the area France for
its part ceded its lands to India in the
1950s and India had hoped the Portugal
would do the same and so it asked if the
country was open to handing Goa back and
when it would do so the Portuguese
response was that they were happy to do
that roughly five minutes after the heat
death of the universe and the reason
that Portugal refused was that unlike
Britain or France the Portuguese
government held no distinction between
overseas territories and Portugal itself
shockingly the Indian government wasn't
unhappy with this and so built up its
military on the border and started to
hint that it would invade the Portuguese
knew that they couldn't resist and so
they turned to a third party to
negotiate the British in a Twist that
was shock exactly zero people the Indian
government wasn't willing to be lectured
by their formal Colonial Masters and
what lands they were entitled to and so
relations got worse in India sanctioned
Portugal the Indian government continued
with the Diplomatic route until 1960
when it decided to just conquer the
lands instead in December 1961 the
Indian army entered Goa and in two days
it had been overrun and the Portuguese
Garrison there had surrendered so how
exactly did the world react well when
the invasion occurred the Soviet Premier
Nikita Khrushchev was visiting the
country and along with the rest of the
Communist world he congratulated the
Indians on making their country whole
again with one notable exception China
because the response there was mostly
non-existent because well they were busy
planning for a thing but as for the rest
of the world well the Portuguese of
course were none too pleased but they
had one trick up their sleeve NATO The
Hope was that since Portugal sir Goa as
a part of the country proper NATO would
do the same it did not instead most NATO
Nations condemned The Invasion demanded
that India withdraw and some placed
India under sanction Britain was less
harsh in its condemnation and largely
blamed Portugal for not accepting the
inevitable but beyond this there was
nothing the world really could do no
nation in NATO cared to do more than the
absolute bare minimum to defend the
dying Portuguese Empire and India knew
this furthermore it was difficult for
Portugal or its allies to retaliate
because the overwhelming majority of
goa's population wanted to join India
after which there was nothing more to be
done and so everybody accepted it almost
immediately thereafter of course with
the exception being Portugal and it
wasn't until his dictatorship was
overthrown by the military in the 1970s
that the new government formally
acknowledged the loss of Goa after which
the two Nations normalized relations and
everybody moved on and the annexation
was largely forgotten I hope you enjoyed
this episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bizzinette Kelly
moneymaker call show wolf Sky Chappelle
kartoitska Jerry lamdin Alex Schwinn
Adam's daughter Jordan Longley rod D
Martin why in hockey Marcus arsner
Captain psydog Marvin Castle Spencer
Lightfoot Winston caywood boogly Wiggly
Daniel tobian commune Miss izet Gustav
Swan Aaron the white Anthony Beckett the
mcwhopper Maggie Paskowski copper tone
spinning three plates she went in words
about books podcast and Charles the
first